تشهد المناطق المتضرره ساعات حرجه بعد
تضاؤل فرص العثور على ناجين من دخول المدن
والبلدات المنكوبه يومها الخامس بعد
الزلزال وهذه الحكومه السوريه تعلن مناطق
حلب واللاذقيه وادلب وحمى منكوبه جراء
الزلزال اداره الكوارث التركيه اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
18,342 واكثر من 74 الف مصاب كما ذكرت
اداره الكوارث التركيه انه تم اجلاء نحو
76 الف شخص من المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
وزير البيئه التركيه تحدث عن نصب نحو 25
الف خيمه في غاز عنتاب لوائي متضرري زلزال
وقال ان السلطات تقيم حاليا اوضاع المباني
المتضرره من الزلزال مشيرا الى ان الحكومه
ستعمل على اعاده الاعمار وعوده الحياه
لطبيعتها في اقرب وقت ممكن وانها ستطلق
اكبر
اسكان في تاريخ البلاد ضمن 10 ولايات
تضررت بفعل الزلزال
[موسيقى]